female alright this is gonna yield some
yeah anime self-driving cars it's a big
old video we've been working on for a
few weeks already just doing an rnd and
now it's finally time to shoot and film
so that makes me a little nervous I see
you may have heard of this app called
the face app but it'll make you old
it'll make you a member of the opposite
sex I think it'd be really funny to see
kind of who wore it better who looks
best when these ridiculous filters are
applied to someone's face I'm pretty
sure it's all like machine learning like
neural network stuff so it does a really
good job of like matching your hair
color and fitting everything to your
face obviously I'm gonna win every
category
we got your face smile make me smile
uncanny it's student female Tyler thank
you I didn't know I cleaned up so nicely
hold on
yeah and it moves up your smile lines
like you're crazy like that actually
looks like my teeth I wouldn't be able
to tell if I saw that old red monsoon
all right that's pretty good Hollywood
gave me a five o'clock shadow
female you kind of looked like a young
Princess Leia there's a man one two that
makes you look more manly okay this is
gonna yield some yeah it's creepy
because I'm so dead in the eyes in this
picture too that it's like you feel less
bad about me
whoa I still have bags in there I need
some concealer the manly filter just
makes you do smiling Nick I think it
worked on because I had clearly defined
lines here should be M word oh did this
video anime self-driving cars it's very
challenging video because it's big it's
a big old video we have a seven and a
half page script for it we've been
working on it for a few weeks already
just doing an rnd and now it's finally
time to shoot and film the actual video
as you guys have seen there's a lot
building up to this video and I don't
want to fail anyone so this is actually
the first anime video that I'm just
directing all by myself
the other ones Nico basically took the
majority of directing work the concept
itself of the self-driving drag race it
was an idea I was ruminating on for a
very long time so there's a little bit
of learning I think for me to kind of do
here because I know the script the
material is good I know it's gonna look
great afterwards with the previs and the
effects we're doing but is it gonna
click with the style is this anime thing
gonna work it could be too ridiculous
like when you want to go over-the-top
and goofy
you want to play serious these are still
the nuances that I have yet to figure
out so that makes me a little nervous
I'm usually really comfortable going in
this video shoots now after doing so
many years but this one in particular
like every night before I go to bed I'm
like okay imagine every shot like go
through it all in my head all over you
over and over and over and over and over
I'm really excited because everyone is
here and it looks amazing so far the
costumes are turning up right over I'm
really nervous because it's a really big
video and we've documented every stage
of the process up to it so there's a lot
of anticipation I give the chance of
success at about 5%
yeah I gotta kind of I'm kind of getting
cold feet I'm actually really excited
for one small reason Eric from Vsauce
let me borrow his Rico theta which 360
camera want to see what I just made
using this yeah what I was able to do
was take a full high-quality HDR and use
that to render this image this image the
only lighting in the scene is from this
photo that you guys are seeing in the
Mac here so that's not only providing
reflections but is providing the
lighting there are shots that we're
gonna shoot tonight where the 3d cars
rendered into an actual environment
we're gonna use this camera to basically
take it an HDR image of the scene so
that we can actually use the real
lighting from the scene to influence the
render of the car in theory I hope we'll
see if that actually works in harmony in
practice to shoot this video we've got
to break it down into a couple parts we
have a lot of stuff at the starting line
of the race we have to do all that it's
at night the thing that makes this
really challenging though because this
is an anime video we have to get tons
and tons and tons and tons of shots we
can't shoot this like a normal video
like I can go out and shoot like
coverage like alright just act out the
scene here but I'm not gonna use that
that's more for the actors to get like
into the scene and understand the
dynamics of their lines I know at the
end here when we're editing it I'm gonna
need four shots of them talking every
single angle and just constantly showing
new shots trying to repeat shots as
little as possible because when you're
doing anime style
storytelling on video you want a
specific shot to stand out suddenly and
people go home that's an important
moment there's lots of important moments
in this piece so I need to come up with
a bunch of important shots and differ
looking shots for these moments so that
way they kind of stand out and get in
your face feel like they're more like
I'm illustrating it not just pointing a
camera at it and hoping things work out
basically executing the tripod and the
camera on it the battery just just
that's the first priority and then I'm
have these guys kind of just get the
lights on the same tripod or boom we're
gonna do the first shots the dolly shot
my character's name is Racer Z which i
think is the coolest possible name you
could have as a racer because if your
name like has an X Rosina you're like
automatic three steps ahead Clinton
Jones the pony sure our starring boy
couldn't still fun to work with not only
does he actually like anime he gets the
genre super fun to work with on set he's
such a goofy friendly awesome guy I am
set out to honor my father's legacy my
artistic eye I can't have like I can't
have him wear this right after a break
his chaos chance Mason Yash may shock
chase me stick me son obviously he has
to be in this video
double people have mentioned that like
oh she's always like cast as bad guys in
these anime videos he's got that natural
persona though he loves wearing like
lots of blacks that's the actor Cole
kind of presentation that an anime bad
guy should have you know it's like he's
kind of model of his own personal style
after anime villains ideally your
villains are just as cool as your hero's
active impossible
I've studied that code for years
and then we're gonna get us straight up
to the lens of you yelling in the same
take you separate setups all right on a
lure we hit her up brought her and she
boom right into it understood the vibe
right away it was just perfect she threw
all those giant anime glasses it's the
enormous eyes really because he think
it's the glasses but my name is Anna and
I play Angela and that's shoot and
Angela is a very loving girlfriend and
she takes the passenger seats in these
racing career but she's actually has her
PhD and she's she doesn't know who her
parents are she was left as baby in a
bundle on the doorstep
[Music]
Luna the dog is in it she's got weird
ass bug eyes her there look they look
like they got a disease man that's what
they look like yeah you gotta working on
that screen huh all right let's do all
thing who do you look like you look like
that actor yeah you do look like some
actor sir you Patrick Stewart I have a
photo sir Patrick Stewart with hair on
my phone
don't be all random don't isn't that no
photo of Patrick Stewart with hair on
your phone so they weren't sure if they
could run a TV show with a bald actor so
they tried a wig test on him female Nick
ready to transcend female all right oh
my god I look like I'm like a homeless
female Sam look like
it's kind of Rosalie oh my god dude
don't get too excited oh yeah oh yeah
yeah that's me yes you know that's much
better
okay I'm gonna blow your mind yet again
this is my little whoa no way here we go
you know one you know one or just Gabe
all right which one is this too much of
that green jar juice what your face look
at what is happening to your lips what
does it do didn't know what to do with
is my teeth coming out of the bottom of
her metal didn't know what to do there
one big to me it was like where do I put
the teeth if you guys could tell us who
wore it better
that'd be great we love your opinions to
validate validate ours
Danny gets really really sick what are
you saying about me tell me pretty we
then also have our green screen day
where we film all the characters in the
cars driving sitting in the cars
observing the race from inside the car
that's a big part of the video
well first off we're using real cars not
imaginary self-driving cars so why is
that a challenge
in my channel version of this world
self-driving cars don't have steering
wheels but unfortunately we're using
Clint's car and his car actually has a
steering wheel how are we gonna get rid
of it it's actually dumb and dead simple
no steering wheel on this side whoa whoa
did I just blow your mind we're gonna
film in the passenger city all day flip
all the footage 180 degrees and it's
gonna look like he's sitting in the
right side of the car wait for real yeah
you have to
backwards and then we'll flip it oh I
made these lines backwards now man in
the movie Titanic they actually had to
do this
apparently they built the entire
exterior Titanic set with the starboard
side of the ship
facing the port which is incorrect
that's what the port side
starboard side today screwed up really
bad so in all those exterior shots of
the Titanic when they're like running up
to the boat and everything - they had to
flip those all 180 degrees that means
they'd go through and taint all the
sines backwards all the words backwards
make sure all everyone's costumes were
flipping the huge pain in the ass
thankfully we're in a much easier
situation but I took a little bit of
inspiration from that a little cinema
lesson so for our green-screen day we're
trying to figure out if there's any way
to avoid having the green-screen in
every single shot because that's going
to add a lot of the effects work for us
afterwards
honestly the visual effect itself is not
that hard for the green-screen
you got the green put a plate there but
it's looking like we're gonna have
dozens of them if we went that route and
we already have at least two minutes
worth of full CG car racing so
immediately two options came up a TV or
a projector my prediction is that the
sad truth is then either these will
really work out here's the issue right
now is that this projector we need to
have it at least compete with these
lights so I don't know if this will be
good for like a background situation
where we're just projecting it onto
something or if we can actually make us
do like wiping like street lights it's a
nice projector but here's the issues
that we're competing with these two
aperture LED lights which are very
bright I highly recommend them but the
yeah I'll just blow out they predict
your anime lines so it's like you don't
want the projector in the break room
yeah you can't it's enough Ren wants to
just take a giant big screen LED TV and
put it behind the window and just play
enemy lines on and now we don't have to
give you green space pros and cons of a
TV it's very bright we're gonna have
light wrapping around his bright
reflective helmet and it'll actually
look very realistic because it is real
so what we're gonna have to do is we're
have to have two people like holding it
with a cable running to a laptop showing
whatever's on screen like what happens
what I need to move the camera I mean at
that rate we're basically just gonna
hire two people for like half a day just
hold this TV and it's like a little to
the left
alright it's not moving stop wiggling it
because like you know it's like that I
just don't see that being practical the
projectors not working the TV's not
working I think it was just time to go
old-fashioned style on this and just
wiggle those dang lights I mean at the
end of the day ultimately we're just
trying to get the effect of sweet legs
and some flashing lights moving past the
cart to imply motion yeah Ren's got
really good upper-body strength and
endurance
[Music]
[Applause]
I was like there we go
that's that's how you know you shook it
right at the end of the day everything
turned out really well the footage looks
gorgeous something else is happening
though in the very near future as much
as I want to be here and finish this
video and keep editing it and get it
perfect and work on the VFX there's
actually a ticking time bomb living in
my home right now and his name is my son
here on the set
Oh flinch fight these videos wouldn't be
possible without our patrons thank you
Richard Linder and Rory JC caylen and
Andrew Dodi of Encino that date was for
you this stretch is for you Taylor
Dunbar you complete me thank you James
Bailey and thank you blitz cube I mean a
lot to us yo shout out to Brian and
music thank you couldn't do this without
you man you can't forget about my boy
Richard Blackburn thanks man
once again thanks for our patrons if
you're interested in supporting us go to
patreon.com/scishow